now as of the comment made by aaron
rodgers regarding uncertain futures
myself included brett favre was on
sirius xm nfl radio on monday here's
what he had to say
about the things that aaron rodgers said
i wouldn't pay much attention to it i
think frustration disappointment hurt
pain
all
were in that
uh that sound bite
look
there's no way the packers would do
anything to jeopardize losing aaron
they already have brett they already
have brett it's too late for that they
already have and you were his surrogate
last may when he was upset and he was
talking to you and you were talking
to media about why he's upset they've
already rocked the boat this is just
some of the water splashing into it no
they did you're right there's no doubt
about that what i think he's trying to
say is
aaron was so awesome this year and it's
so apparent to everybody that they got
to get on his knee on their knees and
they're going to kiss his feet is what
he's basically saying i think i mean but
you're right i mean they already made
the mistake to give him that inkling
that signal to like hey
we might be done with you but um of
course this year
that conversation's nowhere near in
their wheelhouse and of course it falls
back into their face in a big way right
now but the way we're talking about it
and all that so yeah right now the whole
organization is trying to you know put
toothpaste back in the bottle to a
degree here you heard matt lefore like i
don't know if that makes sense or not
bottle of toothpaste i don't know i got
i got some tubes of toothpaste well yeah
you're right right but but i mean we saw
what matt lafleur said the other day
i mean
he's telling you the heart and soul the
culture of the team is that guy so they
need him back if they don't have him
they're just a solid football team
they're not on the cusp of being a
really good great team like they were
this year so uh i think that's what
favre saying and i mean you you do agree
i mean roger yeah i'm sure some of that
was frustration hurt
killed by it you know i disagree though
i disagree with this right brett favre
was trying to explain it from his own
perspective brett favre is far more
emotional and spontaneous than rogers
yeah it's very calculated and reasoned
so farv may have blurted something like
that out in the moment because you know
i mean farve's just kind of like not
even really thinking about it hey i got
to go do this press conference and i'm
upset and i said something you know who
cares i'm just being me
aaron rodgers
has a strategy that that's the
difference between the two so uh and
here's here's the other side of it
because look i give mark murphy a ton of
credit he does a great job as the ceo of
the team he's not the owner of the team
though and i think at a certain level
i i think that that mark murphy was
trying to set up a tom brady jimmy
garoppolo thing
where having jordan love there
sparked and i think brady was the same
age yeah if not a little older when they
drafted jimmy garoppolo with the second
round pick in 20 i think he was a little
older right right so
i i and look at what it did they hadn't
won a super bowl in 10 years
the arrival of garoppolo unlocked
another run
of three super bowls right right right
and and tom
was upset by it by all accounts at the
time and since then he was upset by it
right and he channeled it
in a certain direction and they won
three more super bowls so i i can't help
but wonder whether or not mark murphy
thought you know what here's what we're
gonna do yeah i only have one super bowl
right
it's gonna light a fire under his ass
and we're gonna get another super bowl
or two before we we float him on a sheet
of ice yeah probably but there's a
difference there's a difference and the
difference is
new england's team was really good
and they were set up
and brady the years before that was one
of the downfalls of the team yeah i just
said that everybody he was one of the
downfalls that's why they drafted
garoppolo they didn't draft garoppolo
because they were like man brady's still
top five let's draft a guy so we can
trade him four years from now and you
know never really do anything with them
they were concerned the 2013 afc
championship game against peyton manning
and company the broncos went all out to
stop legarrette blunt they left people
wide open all over the field for tom
brady to hit he couldn't hit anything
new england went into the off season
going damn i don't know what's going on
we might not he might not be around for
much longer so that's why they did it
this is vice versa this is like stupid
this is like wait our guy's still
awesome we don't have the team but let's
draft the guy behind the awesome guy we
got let's draft a guy behind the one
position we don't need help on in the
football team that's where it's
different and that makes no sense
let's take a look at where and how they
got their skill position players devante
adams a second round pick in the year
that jimmy garoppolo was the second
round pick of the packers and then
everyone else fifth round marquez valdez
scandling equinemia saint brown sixth
round alan lazard undrafted free agent
robert tunyan undrafted free agent and i
really do think there was an element of
a middle finger to aaron rodgers by
taking no
receivers or pass catching tight ends
two straight years a draft two straight
years yeah yeah i mean i don't i don't
know and this past year this past year
you they could have chase claypool could
you imagine that team with chase
claypool i mean did you imagine the the
chiefs had tyree kill sammy watkins and
travis kelsey and drafted nicole hardman
in the second round you know and clyde
edwards hilaire in the first round you
know that that's where i just want ever
that's where i get angered because of
the talk and then you know the
negativity it's you know rogers and it's
his fault and it's his fault and it's
roger's fault and i just it's not apples
to apples it's not fair that way it's
not fair to him and they've done him an
injustice that way and now they've put
him in that conversation and he's very
aware of that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports